perform a dilation on the coordinate
plane the dilation should be centered at
nine negative nine and have a scale
factor of three so get our dilation tool
out we'll center it actually all right
so it's already actually centered at
nine negative nine we can put this
wherever we want but let's center it at
nine
nine negative nine and we wanna scale
this up by three so one way to think
about it is pick any of these points
right over here
and they're going to have to get three
times three times further away from our
center of dilation so for example this
point c right actually let's think about
these points where they actually want us
to fill something in so point a right
over right over here it is it is at the
point 4 negative three so in the x
direction in the x direction it is five
it is five less than nine it is five
less than nine we want it to be three
times further than nine so we want it to
be 15 less than nine so we want the x
coordinate of a
nine minus fifteen is negative six we
want it to go to negative six
and likewise we want its y coordinate to
be three times further so right now
let's see it is at negative three
relative to negative nine so it is six
more on the y direction we want it to be
18 more 18 more than negative nine would
be positive nine so point a should map
to negative six
comma nine and that should give us
enough information to just make sure
that we are dilating up by a factor of
three so let's see
whoops
let's dilate up by a factor of three so
we wanna get the the image of point a to
the point negative 6 comma 9. so
we are there
there we go we have dilated it up and
then we could even look where the point
that corresponds to e has mapped to and
you can look at each direction it's
three times further e is now at negative
six
e is at negative six
comma negative three
negative
three the images of points a and e are
three times as far as the original
points
as the original three times far apart i
should say as the original points and
they're three times further from our
center of dilation right over you see
for example the point e is that has the
x coordinate of 4 which is 5 less now it
is at negative 6 which is 15 less than
our then our center of dilation and the
same thing true it's e
it's y coordinate is two more and now
after we mapped it its y coordinate is
six more than our center of dilation
got it right